fair warning this video contains a lot
of swearing guns
blood shooting violence and the list
goes on
viewer discretion is most definitely
advised
so this is the story how chris rock
broke my leg
can't believe i'm using that as a title
it's a good title
it's a great story back in 2019 i
received an email
from none other than darren lynn bausman
who had been the director of saw two
three and four he's also a practicing
magician and he stumbled upon my videos
i'm a i don't wanna say i'm an amateur
magician because that that makes me
sound like i can actually do
cool [ __ ] i can't do anything cool i
have a love and affection for
magic and cards and magic tricks in this
uh kind of quest to learn about how
certain gimmicks work and how slight of
hand works
i found a few magicians that i really
kind of
uh honed in on and i just like them it's
a guy named
chris ramsay who cast in this movie was
the first youtube kind of personality
he's a street magic guy kind of like
david blaine but he teaches how to
tutorials on his channel and so i've
watched
10 hours of his videos and darren sends
me this email it says
let me know if you want to die in a saw
movie dot dot dot when i first got the
job i texted him i
emailed him i said hey my name is darren
you don't know me i directed the song
movies i want to put you on my next
movie and i think he kind of
like yeah sure okay great i have never
responded faster to an email and then i
called him four weeks before we started
filming i said no i'm not joking you're
here in three weeks
[Music]
so july 3rd 2019 i land in toronto for
my first day
on set of the new saw movie just landed
in toronto
off to i guess makeup and or i'm getting
fitted with a prosthetic
and going through some makeup stuff and
meeting the stunt guy
apparently i'm doing a stunt get all
that sorted today before
before spiral i think the tentative name
for this was the
organ donor which is why you have the
organ donor signs kind of everywhere as
you can see here
the uh my formal title before i had my
official name
as a character was crack punk
this is the wardrobe they set me up with
which was really dope i had never
experienced this before i'd never been
on a major movie set
before they had to dress me up as this
sort of drug dealer so once they sent me
the script i read through it and i found
out that i actually have
speaking lines adjacent to or opposite
to
max mangala and chris rock's character
who are both police officers in this
movie finding that out that i'm in
i have a speaking role i'm so fortunate
to be in that position because i'm not
an actor
and so i'm really really grateful for
that and i i i took that challenge
head-on
and couldn't wait to uh couldn't wait to
to meet my counterparts
and be a part of this movie so for the
first trip i got there they actually
just uh they sent me down to get my
prosthetic
leg done on our way to get fitted for
prosthetic legs so
wardrobe check rehearse next week
falling through a glass table they
wanted to go with real glass initially
and i think we opted for the candy which
i'm okay with
because in this scene i get tackled
crashing through a glass table
and my my leg is then is then broken and
exposed so we needed to make that fake
leg i do then
this is wild look at this effigy
once that was done i flew back home and
a couple weeks later they called me to
fly back in
to start filming this is my this is my
trailer by the way i'd never had a
trailer before i'd never experienced
that
so it was it was kind of surreal and the
funny part is
that you know uh samuel jackson was in
this movie as well
and i'm in my trailer and i i
i look through the blinds and i see sam
jackson just chilling
lounging uh i i i take a picture of him
just lounging i didn't send this to
anybody this is just for me
i'm showing it here this is me
fangirling at seeing sam jackson as
close as i got to sam jackson on set
uh why am i showing this uh then i got
to meet the stunt coordinators who are
absolute legends these guys have worked
on a lot of movies and they basically
briefed me
saying that i have an option in this
movie to
perform my own stunts or to get a stunt
double to do it for me the stunts that i
i would be performing weren't
necessarily life-threatening i mean
anything can go wrong obviously but they
were just gonna hurt and they were gonna
suck a bit and i thought man
this is a once-in-a-lifetime experience
go big or go home
let's practice these stunts so i had two
stunts to do
the first one was an exploding
paint bomb that goes off in my face
and the second was me being tackled
through a glass table
falling down on my back straight to the
floor no matter how much padding you
have
the wind's gonna get knocked out of you
three two
one that was good nice you know what
you're fine so after practicing that
they then
put me into hair and makeup i got to put
on all my jewels i got to
get a fake scar on the side of my face
which was really dope and then i also
got to put on this amazing prosthetic
which looks so
gross and gory shield your eyes if
you're at all squeamish
[Music]
so this is what was fitted over my leg
basically it's a big
sock that's like got like a a bone
texture this was filled with like prop
blood as well but this is my actual leg
like they molded this
from my leg and you basically put it on
like a sock
or like pants and then your sock would
cover this part you know
my pants my shorts would have covered
this part so what an amazing
work of art this is very heavy too this
is made of like silicone
it gets sweaty very quickly but it's
something that i cherish and i asked
them i was like can i keep this
they were very reluctant to let it go in
case they needed pickup shots or in case
i damaged it and they needed it again
for another shot uh but i i'd eventually
convinced them so thank you guys for
that thank you the prop department for
letting me
hold on to this memorabilia i've been
sitting on it for two years now and i
couldn't show it until now so i'm very
happy about that
yeah still smells like my leg now once
that was all set it was time to roll the
camera
and here without any further ado is my
scene from spiral
the book of saul
just trying to get a five minute my lady
it's our anniversary we're trying to
celebrate trying to do something special
can i get a phone how about how about
this ipad well it's got everything on it
i got i got passcodes we got hulu
uh uber eats host mates lots of food
lots of food let me see that yo man get
the [ __ ] out of that
[ __ ] hungry to you no no you got
everything it don't fit though
why don't you come down get the [ __ ] out
of here come back when you get some
money oh
okay okay i need money i need money no
no wait wait wait wait i got something i
got some money
i got some money hold up a second hold
up for a second all right
all right sit it down baby come on
all right so now he's put this uh he's
put this little explosive
you know i don't know that it's an
explosive but he puts it inside a bucket
which i'm gonna hoist up into my window
thinking it's money for the drugs
what happened there basically what i'm
doing at this point
is i'm staring point blank in a paint
can
that is attached to a tube filled with
blue paint
attached to a compressor going
getting ready to fire one massive blue
load of paint into my face
you know what's gonna happen and so the
hardest part of the scene was not to
anticipate it and just
to trust that i wasn't going to get
seriously injured and they're counting
down three two one
i i have to like just pretend that you
know what the hell is that thing
and then boom now in this shot up this
got behind my eyelids
up my nose i think i had blue boogers
for like the next two days
and now for the next couple days i would
have to be made up
in this blue they would have to repaint
me this way uh for every
you know consecutive scene that we would
shoot in this scene
all right
back inside get back inside
come on [ __ ]
so at this point what's really cool is
that i had this airsoft gun
the idea was as soon as they kicked that
door open
i would spray this gun you know across
the room
paint my eye they actually rigged up
squibs and what squibs are they're small
explosives
that look like like bullet holes are put
into the doors this door already had all
these squibs in it so we only had a few
chances a very expensive thing to do i
guess and i had this airsoft gun
and so i had to kind of time it to where
it would follow the line of the squibs
so those explosions and the doors are
not cgi those are real practical
effects so after i did this my gun jams
and
then this happens
boom i get tackled into a table here's
another angle from one of the monitors
when we shot this
uh that was me the person who tackled me
was obviously chris rock's
stunt double who did an amazing job
there they bring someone else in for
that
as you saw before with practicing i had
mattresses before this time
it's just a little balsa wood table a
carpet with some padding
and then i had padding on my body as
well but let me tell you when you're
going from this
to flat on the ground no matter how much
padding you put like it wasn't it was
like this it wasn't
it had to look like a floor so it wasn't
like a gym mat or anything yeah there
was not much padding there was basically
a carpet the hardest part of that
is not not the falling because i did
this in two takes
the first take my head came way too
close to the radiator
and then uh because i kind of leapt back
and the stunt coordinator uh he was very
scared at that point because i could
have bought my head
so he was just reassuring me that i have
to go from here
to straight down rather than fly back
and then i nailed it in the second take
but the hard part for me
wasn't the falling it was you have to
remember to keep acting
afterwards and instinctively as soon as
i hit the ground and the wind left my
lungs you're left in kind of a shock
it's like getting hit over the head
you're like ugh
for a second you're left in shock and in
days but i couldn't afford to be dazed
because the scene has to go on
i got to be screaming for my leg here
because my leg is apparently busted open
so as soon as they hit me on the ground
you for a second i hesitate and then i
go
ah and then i get back into it so i was
really proud of myself for keeping
my composure uh during that scene
you gotta make it easy for the customer
skis
[ __ ] like
[Music]
here we go you want me to tag you
when we were rehearsing chris rock's
always coming up with jokes on the spot
because
comedy is very situational and he's such
a great comedian and writer
that he takes the takes that rehearsal
time to try and flesh out some new jokes
that might just come to him that might
be really funny
and so he takes out his phone he was
telling the director and everybody else
i'm gonna i'm gonna film this take a
picture like oh look at your leg how
it's busted up and taking a picture of
it i thought that was hilarious
and so when he was running through in
practice so as soon as he leaned over
and said you want a picture for the gram
i said don't forget to tag me
[ __ ]
and chris starts laughing and he's like
that's funny
i'm gonna use that so i actually kind of
fed him a joke there which i'm so proud
of and i don't know what came over me
but chris used that in the scene where
he goes you want me to tag you you want
me to tag you that was something i
actually
threw to him so i was really honored
that he used that it felt good
mama here we go you want me to tag you
you see this man before i tell you [ __ ]
why because you're worried about that
bone sticking out your leg why don't you
let me sterilize it
says betty stop please everybody knows
that [ __ ] benny ritz
oh she's one of my best customers man
when was the last time you saw him i
seen a [ __ ] in two days man
over the streets of my [ __ ] deed
[ __ ] this snitch [ __ ]
so there you have it that is the story
of how chris rock broke my leg and how i
made it into
the movie spiral the book of saw
such an incredible journey something i
would never
in a million years think would ever
happen to me and i'm so grateful it did
you can see the new saw movie in
theaters playing right now thanks for
watching don't forget to leave a like
and subscribe we'll see on the next
video peace right
we definitely have memories of working
chris ramsay that was a really fun
couple of days on set for us
um it was you know mostly fun because
chris is really good
he was really good in the movie it's
very natural and funny
and great to have around um
and you know you can actually do magic
that's impossible this guy's really
really really
really
[Music]